[Music]
before we start i just want to mention
that only 20.5 percent of you are subbed
if you enjoy the content please consider
liking subscribing
to support the channel hey everyone
welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing severus
snape harry potter
and the deathly hallows more
specifically we're going to be
addressing
one large aspect of the harry potter
story harry's trust in snape
throughout the series harry flip-flops
with snape the two go back and forth
constantly
snape is harry's professor his
instructor is elder
but he's also the man that was turned
down by harry's mother
what this meant for their relationship
is that they would never truly get along
furthermore snape saw so much of james
potter his childhood bully in harry
this was an aspect that he found
difficult to overcome
however what's revealed in his final
moments is that snape also saw an aspect
of harry's mother
in harry her eyes this is something that
he wouldn't admit
until he was an inch from death you see
snape was a proud man
he always tried to remain stoic and
didn't like to admit when he was wrong
but the truth is that snape was wrong
and he knew it he knew that he shouldn't
have ever blamed an innocent young boy
for the actions of his parents but at
the same time
snape is snape and he did what he had to
do to cope with his unfortunate
circumstance
so provided that snape was a former
death eater bullied harry immensely
throughout the course of his life
and murdered dumbledore in front of him
it's hard to imagine how harry could
have ever trusted him
even on his deathbed nevertheless in the
deathly hallows
when snape is falling to pieces after
being viciously attacked by nagini
harry walks up to a vulnerable shadow of
the snape that he knew
at this stage harry collects snape's
tears
a terrible rasping gurgling noise issued
from snape's throat
take it take it something more than
blood was leaking from snape
silvery blue neither gas nor liquid it
gushed from his mouth
and his ears and his eyes and harry knew
what it was
but did not know what to do a flask
conjured from thin air was thrust into
his shaking hand by hermione
harry lifted the silvery substance into
it with his wand
when the flask was full to the brim and
snape looked as though there was no
blood left in him
his grip on harry's robes slackened in
this scene
snape gives harry his tears so that
harry can bring them to the pensive
the purpose of this is simple give harry
the full story
and help him to understand his tragedy
the prince's tale
harry approaches the pensive exhausted
withered and war-torn
welcoming and escape from his own
reality the stone bends of lay
in the cabinet where it had always been
harry heaved it onto the desk and poured
snape's memories into the wide basin
with its runic markings around the edge
to escape into someone else's head
would be a blessed relief nothing that
even snape had left him
could be worse than his own thoughts at
this point harry finally figures out the
snape was actually one of the good guys
snape's past is put on display his
tragedy
bullying at the hand of harry's father a
desperate attempt to save the life
of harry's mother and conversations with
dumbledore
revealing his true motivations suddenly
everything was so clear but what i've
always wondered about this scene is
why did harry trust snape at this stage
snape hadn't proved himself as one of
the good guys
sure voldemort had attack snape but
voldemort was a ruthless dark wizard
who was known to have turned on his own
out of anger couldn't snape's tears have
been one final distraction
one last service for a devout follower
of the dark lord
to me there are two things that
immediately come to mind for how
snape could have played harry the first
possibility is of course that snape
was dying but remained loyal to
voldemort regardless
in this scenario snape very well could
have tampered with his memories
and sent harry to his death the next
possibility is that snape wasn't
actually dying at all
and that it was all a big ruse as malfoy
was the one to disarm dumbledore
it's not entirely unreasonable to deduce
that malfoy would have told snape about
this
a message that would have been relayed
to voldemort explaining the possibility
of taking ownership
through disarming playing on harry's
emotions the whole snape dying thing
could have been an elaborate setup in
order to put harry in a compromised
position
okay so there are some reasons for why i
think that harry maybe
shouldn't have trusted snape however
i've also got some points supporting
why harry made the right decision in
that moment
first of all seeing snape like this was
entirely uncharted territory
and though apprehensive ahri knew deep
down that snape would never
in any circumstance put himself in this
kind of compromised position
he did not know why he was doing it why
he was approaching the dying man
he did not know what he felt as he saw
snape's white face
and the fingers trying to saunch the
blood wound at his neck harry took off
the invisibility cloak
and looked down upon the man he hated
whose widening black eyes found harry
as he tried to speak harry bent over him
and snape seized the front of his robes
and pulled him close
harry wasn't going in blind he knew the
deception that snape was capable of
but here harry was witnessing a man that
prided himself on his stoicism
completely falling to pieces more
helpless than ever at this stage it
occurs to harry that perhaps snape
is not quite as bad as he always thought
harry didn't know why
but he somehow knew that he needed to
approach snape in these final moments
and he was certainly right about that
snape died looking into the eyes of a
boy that was more significant to him
than harry ever knew this was the boy
that shed the same face of the man that
bullied him
for his entire childhood and the eyes of
the only woman
that he ever loved the same woman that
spared her own life
to save this boy with his final breaths
in the film version
snape looked straight into harry's face
and uttered the iconic line
you have your mother's eyes these were
the same eyes that caused snape
more pain than anything else in his
entire life
but at the same time they were the eyes
that enabled snape
to feel love to feel alive
in the book he simply says to harry look
at me
i think that snape's fragility paired
with the fact that dumbledore had always
maintained that snape was on their side
was enough for harry to give him a
chance throughout the final books
dumbledore constantly reaffirmed snape
was on their side
even when repeatedly questioned on this
fact by those around him
everyone else was unconvinced
furthermore dumbledore never explained
why he trusted snape
only that he did so unconditionally even
on the day that snape kills dumbledore
harry raises the topic of snape's
loyalty with him
but he's a very good oklahomans isn't he
sir
said harry whose voice was shaking with
the effort of keeping it steady
and isn't voldemort convinced that
snape's on his side even now
professor how can you be so sure snape's
on our side
dumbledore did not speak for a moment he
looked as though he was trying to make
up his mind about something
at last he said i am sure i trust
severus snape completely and that's it
for this video
i hope that answers the question of why
harry trusted snape
did you guys ever think about this if
you enjoy the content please like the
video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
remember the mind is not a book to be
opened at will
and examined at leisure
you